fedex spending some time up with uh the
cutouts representing the negro league
stars
out to second base waiting for it is
segura
and he throws out jd davis
one two three go the mets here in the
top of the first gene segura leading off
today
right field it's pretty deep conforto's
going back it is off the scoreboard
conforto crashes into the scoreboard
segora is on his way to third he'll get
there sliding
[Music]
a seven-game hitting streak and gene
segura has his first triple of the year
now reece had a nice night last night
he's two for six with three rbis in this
series off the hands loop towards center
and it'll drop in for a hit segora
scores in the phillies
five pitches into this game have a one
nothing lead everyone's out toward left
center field it's not deep it's gonna
drop for a hit hoskins read it well it
was right in front of him so three
straight hits for the phillies
they have runners on first and second
that's eight in a row
for price
spinner up the third base line jimenez
charges
circles throws not in time
i mean that
he swung as hard as he possibly could
and just spun it up the third base line
that is a q shot right there
that one's right through the hole on the
right side harper hits second base on
his way to third the throw by hamilton
on one hop and he is out
and now the throw back to first and jt
is back
i like the aggressiveness but billy
hamilton did a really nice job of
closing you know he's got great speed he
closes on this ball and throws a perfect
strike
and jd hits one down to first off the
glove of hoskins and enter right field
and jd is aboard well hoskins made a
play just like that
last night going to his right
basement
he couldn't quite secure this one and
davis is on
and canoe hits one into left center
that's going to fall in for a base hit
jd stops at second
and canoe is aboard with a soft single
to left center
and the mets have two men on in the
fourth
and he gets hit by the pitch and that'll
load the bases
so ramos gets plunked by wheeler first
battered zach is hit this year
shoots one over the bag that's a fair
ball going down the line davis is in
canoe will score lumbering to third is
lamos the throw by bruce and ramos is
out at third but two runs score on the
play as guillermo gives the match the
lead
luis guillorme comes through again
shoots one over the bag to drive in a
pair and the mets go in front
first pitch to bone swing and a ground
ball base it by the diving shortstop
jumenez out into left center home a big
turn at first but he'll hold right there
as nimmo gets the ball back in but
home has a lead off single here to start
the phil's fourth nice pitch priscilla
picks off the inside corner to get knapp
second time he's throwing that same
pitch to knapp to get the strikeout and
kingery down on strikes so priscilla
with back-to-back strikeouts to finish
off the bottom of the fourth a shutdown
inning after the mets got on the lead
2-1 new york
3-2 to smith
and a call strike three right on the
outside part of the plate got him
looking beautiful pitch in the outside
part he knew it this time i think he
argued about a couple of those outside
fastballs in the back prior canoe hits
one down the right field side harper
looks up at the wall and it goes off the
fence canoe on his way to second and
harper's throat comes in too late and
robbie canoe's got a two out double his
second hit of the day bullet back to the
box and gloved by wheeler beginning he's
open 1-3 on the put out
no runs a hit man left in scoring
position after the double by canoe
middle of the six philly's trailer by
one
over the third it's a fair ball and hit
the third base bag and skip behind jd
davis and real muto on his way to second
as they're sliding
down the right field line conforto
trying to run it down it's in for a base
hit and goes to the wall real muto to
score the throw to second rbi double for
alec balm
and the phillies have tied it up in two
touch of the hitter came on
and replaced jay bruce who left after
flying out to right field in the air to
left field that was a hangar going back
on it as nimbo it is
gone two-run home run for catch and the
phillies take the lead it's a 4-2 ball
game
third base line davis charges from the
grass throws not in time off the glove
of smith here comes walker he'll score
over to third harper
second error of the inning for the vets
but i think this one will go on smith
the first baseman and it'll be an
infield hit for jt
and a line drive base in it to center
field another runal score rbi single for
dd and the phillies lead it six to two
hit hard down the left field line and
that's an extra base set for jd davis
his second hit of the day
and he pulls it at second base with a
two out double
ground ball over the mounds scooped up
by jimenez throws not in time smith
wasn't even on the bag i think he was
shocked that his shortstop got to it and
it's an infield hit for kingry that one
is hooked into right center field of
base hit
kingrio
[Music]
the line drive to right field right at
bryce harper and the ball game is over
for the first time since 2015
the phillies have swept out the bets
they win it 6-2
this afternoon they've won three
consecutive games